[Musique]
la soirée de lancement d'une nouvelle
saison est toujours un moment d'émotion
pour le public qui est en demande mais
aussi pour les artistes et les
organisateurs au premier rang comme tous
les autres chantal inspectent le
programme a répété qu' il ya des choses
qui sont intéressantes au niveau
de la danse alors je n'ai pas pris tu as
des gens théâtre parce que je n'ose pas
dire mon âge on est je vais parler
d'avoir un tarif plus intéressant que
l'adhésion
l'adhésion au théâtre mais aussi connaît
moi je vois toujours le verre à moitié
plein et encore une fois on a mis les
bouchées double pour travailler et vous
présenter cette programmation qui arrive
et autant vous dire qu'elle est tout
aussi belles que les autres
le contexte social des gilet jaune a été
lourd de conséquences pour ce monde du
spectacle
et lorsque le programme est enfin
diffusé cette pénombre laisse deviner
les émotions
[Musique]
émond
la culture c'est nous la culture ça
tombe pas su nous ça c'est à dire que la
culture en la fabrique donc c'est bien
d'être fier de ce qu'on a fait de notre
saga de notre maloya
mais il faut continuer à nourrir aussi
une nouvelle génération pour quel moment
donné que de continuer à faire la
musique continue faire du théâtre
continuer à faire du cinéma continue à
faire des chorégraphies et la culture
est un axe important que la culture
structure un individu mais surtout c'est
un vecteur aussi économiques
à l'extérieur la billetterie est prise
d'assaut une ambiance nouvelle pour
certains mais pas pour d'autres a nourri
le ventre ni l'esprit c'est le côté
première scène ici
smith ou via c'était en 1981
10 91
10 80 autres la naissance voilà
et mme a dû jouer
vraiment s'en fait l'intéressant nos
ventes avec plus de 200 fois
pour plus de détails
mon premier création qu'il présente
cette chaufferie donc c'est un honneur
pour moi de pouvoir faire un cognac rien
dans ces lieux là qu'on connaisse un
exutoire c'est un échappatoire aussi des
spectacles qui font voir autre chose on
finira la journée ou la tonte y un
barrage à reste bloquée d'après vos
données voilà les gens là ont leur vie
taux de change relève les théâtres
départementaux vous attendent ainsi
livré tous leurs secrets et toutes leurs
émotions
petite aventure
[Musique]
m